I do still have yes, there are still there are still Swedish berries. Okay, so
So what I what I need so I'm gonna need you, I need you to sit there, I need you just sit there and
and I'm
I'm going to try to explain this movie to you
and now I
Okay, do you want me to start with
the sequel bate ending
Maid Marian's titty costumes
or the extended
description of
The Sheriff of Nottingham being raped with a broomstick when he was a child.
(Off camera) Wow, wow there's a lot of ground to cover here, umm
Oh, how about the opening wehere we see, like the movie basically starts
as Zero Dark Loxley
The Hurt Loxley
Robin of Loxley's Long Half Time Walk
Finding... Saving Private Loxley
You know, it's- it's- it's the Sicario prequel we didn't want or need
The it's it's Sicario, 1282
The Thin Red Loxley
Full Metal Loxley
Not just a war sequence! There is a, there is a a
Semi-automatic ballista
That is, there- there is a sequence
Okay
Every war movie since Saving Private Ryan has a scene where like the entire squad is pinned down
By machine-gun fire and they're like hiding behind like pillars and they've got to like like use a mirror to try like "where is he?"
"I can't oh "and then they gotta like do a flanking maneuver. Yeah. There's that except they're pinned down and
they
They're pinned down by fire from a ballista that can fire like six bolts a second
Just like and they're like and and it's even you know, you've you've got the tower
it's got a dome and there's like a crack in it and the balista is like set in that and then they're down in like
this this like
Open square they're like- like pinned behind like tiny pillars and they try to like look at it in the reflection of it
Oh, yeah and and and all of their all of their armor, so they're wearing like the
a bardiche
you know, so leather jacket with just like, you know metal plates sewn onto it except it has been
Intentionally designed to match like the quilting of a modern flak jacket
They're they're wearing
medievalized
Modern stuff and this goes through the entire thing like. (off camera) Someone really had their hearts
Set on shooting a modern movie, but had
To settle for Robin Hood. Now there's a a
Stylization to it. That is is
I want to like the stylization, I do want to like the stylization like it's it's it's got a sort of V for Vendetta
vibe to a lot of it in
that there's sort of an unreality to it
And that that's it's it's weird
but it's not necessarily bad where where it's just straight up bad is when you get to like
the
acting and the
Writing and
Trying to act the writing
No, it's
This is
This movie was made by Garth Marenghi. This is a Garth Marenghi's Darkplace type movie.
like I know writers who use subtext and they're all cowards
multiple like multiple multiple times throughout the movie characters just straight up say
Exactly like
So so there's this whole plot where like Robin
Where Robin needs to
infiltrate a meeting between the Sheriff of Nottingham and the Cardinal
and
so like it's
Okay, so Robin gets back from the Crusades
Gets back from the war, stuff happens, and he cooks up this plan. Well, actually Jamie Foxx's character
Jamie Foxx is in this movie?
To... remember Morgan Freeman's character from from Prince of Thieves?
Yeah, so he that character has been
merged with Little John
okay, and there's two gags where, so he's a Moor and has thus a
name that I cannot confirm the veracity of
But it is
either Moorish or Arabic or
Or is it as close as the writers cared to get
and there are
multiple instances
of a gag
Very like the old hacky gag where it's like, what's your name?
And then all of the english-speaking characters like struggle to struggle to say it
And he was just like I will just translate it into your language. You may call me John and
Then they reused that at the end where Friar Tuck who speaks Arabic?
You know, it's like what's your name?
it's like how about I just
translate it and call you John
And then that's like the the dip to black for the first couple titles before it then comes back in for the big sequel bait
Reveal that Jamie Dornan is now the actual Sheriff of Nottingham
And that this is like this is this is this is Batman Begins: Robin Hood Edition
There's a chi well, I mean Sharon like so there's it's a title so a Sheriff of Nottingham
Someone else claims the title, and ascends to be Sheriff of Nottingham
- yes, so Robin comes back from the war and
Marian is now
Married or shacked up with this dude, Jamie Dornan
Who is I guess trying to be like a people's revolutionary or something?
it's very unclear what his like goals are but
Will Scarlett, yeah and
He
So
In the climax
In the climax. He sees Marian and Robin kiss and
then in
in the
epilogue
the
Cardinal promotes him to
Sheriff
because he now
hates Robin and so the movie ends with like Robin and
Marian and the gang going out into Sherwood Forest and
so so the end of the movie is like the status is the setup for the like
status quo of
Yes
So we had a placeholder Sheriff of Nottingham, who had terrible things done to him as a boy.
yes, so
So Robin's doing this whole like he's playing both sides. He's like robbing. He's like
robbing, the the the collection plate at church
But he's also like but then during the day he's like schmoozing as as Robin of Loxley he's a noble and you know
man, yeah, they're
the the scene in
The Dark Knight, the dinner scene where
they're all talking and
You know it in the context of the Dark Knight it ends up being this
Interesting little philosophical
conversation and a chance for the movie to engage with like the philosophical idea of
Batman and have characters voice different perspectives on it
They try to recreate that in a scene where?
The sheriff throws a party for the Cardinal and it's like a gambling hall and they're all playing craps
in 1282
Like standing around it's like a craps table like I've said like the stylization is weird, but I'm kind of okay
I want to like the stylization
Yeah, you know, it's it's oh
So they're trying to recreate that
The Dark Knight conversation except the dialogue is just so hack
it's just it's so
Clumsy and bad and like on the nose like characters are just like it's like well sheriff it takes a thief to catch a thief
And
and it's like and
the whole reason ok, Marian isn't so
Marian isn't a noble
In her own, right?
In this one, she's a peasant so the whole reason she's at this party is because Friar Tuck convinces
Convinces the sheriff to send a few invitations
To important people. Um, it's amongst the peasantry which is why Marian and
Will are there
It's an excuse it's an excuse to get some it's an excuse to have them there
and
But that makes it even weirder because it's like because there's multiple scenes where there is a scene, okay?
The sheriff says out loud
They're not my people. They're my subjects
in in one scene
and
And yet he also
Tolerates a tremendous amount, a tremendous amount of insolence from
like the it's it's it's very
Just not clear where it's going
But okay
so I was saying there's this meeting between the cardinal and and
The sheriff that Robin needs to infiltrate and he infiltrates it and he has to like he he sells out Friar Tuck
It's it's a ruse
he does or he does a ruse and infiltrates the
infiltrates the meeting and
They say
Welcome to the big table now
as they like close the doors on the on the private secret meeting and then the moment the doors are closed
It is in in like three seconds of dialogue
okay, so
We're going it's like, all right, so everything is on track with our plan that you and I have cooked up to
fund the
Arabian army
So that they will defeat the English to destabilize the country so that we can seize the crown
And the only reason
Our conspiracy in our long-running, in our like decade-long
conspiracy to destabilize a nation and seize power.
I won't even touch the historical plausibility of a statement like that. I won't even bother.
So that's their plan, okay and
Wait, so which two characters are this?
The cardinal and the sheriff so the cardinal and the sheriff are
conspiring
to fund
The other
Side of the Crusades
Who
Wouldn't be Saladin's army it would be it would be he was the one who fought Richard Lionheart. Okay, so
Yes, so they don't they don't say yeah
We're since we don't quite know where the time line
This actually is since this is a set up but yes there they are funding their funding therefore
they're funding the Muslims as though as though the England had any wealth at that time comparable whatsoever to
Just roll with it
so they're funding the Muslims to
To so that the Muslims will defeat
the English army
Specifically
Thus destabilizing Richard's claim to power
allowing the Sheriff of Nottingham to
Was there any Prince John anywhere in this?
No.
Okay, I guess they're saving
Saving him for the sequel.
The first shot you see of Maid Marion
It's like okay, so she's she's dressed
She's dressed like he you know, the outfit that Princess Jasmine wears when she sneaks out of the palace at the beginning of Aladdin
She's dressed like that
except
okay, she's dressed like that and
She like it crawls through this window into the stable to steal a horse
but then she turns around and like the front of her bodice is just like this deep v-neck with like
Criss crossing laces holding it together
And she's then then Robyn comes in is like and they have this
meet-cute where she's trying to steal a horse because like her neighbor's horse died and
Without a horse to plow their fields, they're all gonna starve and he's like, well the it's like you can just steal my horse
I'll just let you have my horse
You can just you can just steal it like you've stolen my heart already
And then they start making out and then there's an extended montage where they make out. And then Robin gets drafted and the draft letter --
so the the stylization starts subtly. He gets this draft letter,
and the whole thing is like is like an illuminated manuscript. It's like
giant Germanic calligraphy font all down the, like, "By the order of the Sheriff of Nottingham,"
(Offscreen) Yeah I'm pretty sure a draft letter in this context would just be his liege lord calling all his you know subordinate Lords
Yeah, it'd just be a page show you're like your lord has summoned you you can't read anyway so you must
Reading is for priests
And
so he gets that so he goes off to war then you get Zero Dark Loxley for like ten minutes and
Yes, that coat is amazing and and as you can see like extremely V for Vendetta
Yeah, like all these guards. Oh
Yeah thee oh
And they've got riot shields. They've got leather riot shields, like modern police riot shields, like like I said,
Like there's there's elements to the stylization
that I want to like and the whole like it tries really hard to be about like
How
The government like how the wealthy are basically just like exploiting the poor and funding wars for their own
For for their own purposes and
You you know, it's it's this kind of like rise up eat the rich sort of thing
but it's so clumsy and ham-handed and
and really does end up delving into
Like just full-on conspiracy theory territory with the whole
You know
Oh
the the sheriff is, the sheriff and the church are secretly funding the other side so that they can take power and
And it's not about so it tries to be about wealth inequality
but really it's about oh, well, there's some bad rich people and we got to watch out for the bad rich people and
The only person who can stop a bad rich the only person even stop a bad rich person is a good rich person
Yeah, yeah, yeah
So are all Maid Marrion's outfits terrible?
Every single one has just like it ranges between tasteful and absurd amounts of cleavage
There's a
Jamie Foxx is in this movie and he loses his hand during zero-dark Locksley and
Then because so
Robin tries to save
Jane Robin tries to save John's
son from getting beheaded
by
Asshole drill sergeant type and
Okay, so
There's a character in this that it is
basically just
Soap from the
Modern Warfare
Call of Duty games, okay?
like he is pretty much just the character of Soap, you know, he's even got he's got the mustache and
you know dresses in tactical black and it's
It's very very strange
But so raw Robin tries to save John's son from getting beheaded, but he gets he gets killed
and so and then there's like I don't know a
riot of some kind the action is very poorly shot and it's difficult to tell what happens but
John ends up getting away, stow's away on the boat. So they threw it like Robin gets injured
So they throw him on a boat to send him back to England
John stows away on the boat and like stalks
Robin and then is like
You see everything that is wrong with your home. I'm going to teach you to be Batman
And then there's an extended montage
Little John is the mentor?
Little John is yeah a little-little John the the role of
The role of Ra's al Ghul will be played by Little John
Who is Jamie Foxx.
And and then there's this extended montage that okay, you know the montage, you know the training montage in
Batman V Superman that everyone makes fun of yeah where Bruce Wayne is just like Oh, I'm so dark and angry
I'm gonna lift chains. I'm gonna flip tires. Yeah, they do that
And
Everybody walks around with their bows like they're m16s
There's like three swords in the entire movie
Everyone's either using a bow or a crossbow
And the soldiers have leather riot shields
Yep, oh
Which, really, you just use normal Medieval shields, because the whole point of modern riot shields is you can see through them.
Yeah, they've got they have viewport windows in them
Oh, well, I hope Robin's people shoot them through those.
Oh, yeah during during that whole sequence the Molotov cocktails come out
Oh, yeah and like they've got Molotov cocktails and oh
Yeah, and everybody's like there's there's a character wearing a
Bandana with like
Like with like the skull
with this it's
That that's sort of mashup style you work better in a comedy
Like now I'm thinking about I'm thinking about the Mel Brooks
From a parody nothing you like if you want to have your bizarre medieval stylized
You know stuff it can't be in a movie. That's also trying to take itself seriously
It it ends up being a lot like I threw out it I was thinking
Ultraviolet
you know one of those movies that has like an element of just like
absurdly overwrought
Stylization that's trying just like way too hard
but then there isn't some other hook to really get you to buy in, you know, if you're going to compare like
Ultraviolet to
V for Vendetta or if you're going to compare
Like literally anything to the output of Baz Luhrmann
you know you
It's just it's missing that extra a little bit and the fact that like the script is so bad and the characters are like unmemorable
and
They're the there's a whole chase scene there's an extended chase scene where the green screen compositing is
some of the worst I've seen since
honestly like Spawn
Like it it
It just looks so much it looks so flat and
You you can tell
the shake has been added in post because like there's there's just that little difference like the perspective doesn't change
So everything just like slides around but it slides around like way too smooth and mechanically
You know
They it's it's they so they added camera shake in post but the camera shake has no rhyme or reason to it
And it's just it's just kind of floating
floating there and it and so that combined with the fact that everybody just looks like paper cutouts in front of
in a diorama is
It makes it pretty bad and the sequence goes on for like quite a while
so it's not just like oh, here's a shot that like I
Don't know. It's a quick shot. They did what they had to but it's like it keeps coming back to these
composite shots like over and over for a very long time and
So you get a lot of time to keep
Reevaluating how good that matting is
I
feel I feel like there's a ton that
I'm missing or like that. I'm just like forgetting
to mention
Okay, wait wait wait
Okay, Friar Tuck is played by Tim Minchin the the comedian musician
And
he's
Probably actually like the most charming person the cast because Tim Minchin just like exudes charisma
he's a he's a very charming fellow but he's he ends up being out of place and
Yeah, so he's he's the comic relief and
They've basically
It's like they wrote the role for Simon Pegg
but they could only get Tim Minchin and
I don't want that to sound like a slight against Tim Minchin, but it would be a budgetary
For budgetary reasons the part of Simon Pegg will be played by Tim Minchin
and
I don't know like if there's he's okay. He keeps
Everybody has a plot
everybody has a plot or a scheme that like
No, they're all keeping secret that just reminded me of another scene that like makes no sense. So, okay
after Robin,
his first scene back in Nottingham. He goes back to his Manor
Which is just kind of like busted up cuz like it got trashed while he was gone and like Marian comes by to see him
And she's like standing of the doorway like Robin
Are you there?
Robin Robin and and John is like you can't you know
it's like she can't know anything about our plans to like, you know to play both sides against the
against the sheriff like she can't know that we're gonna be like stealing from him but also like
you know doing this like you you need to be
Robin of Loxley the aristocrat to her and it's like
Okay, so he's gonna go downstairs and like just play it up
So he starts movie and then John grabs him again is like you can't go down there
cuz
reasons
And and it's it's really just
An excuse to like not have her involved
For whatever reason but then the reason is that if she were involved like cuz because she and Friar Tuck are also
conspiring to do something
Don't know what
But they're conspiring to do something. Well, I I do know why cuz I saw the rest of it
So like they keep it. They keep it secret for quite a long time. But then she's also keeping secrets from
Jamie Dornan
Who himself also has
Nebulous plans that basically sound like it's it's it's very strange
It's kind of this of all of the anachronisms
the one where Jamie Dornan is basically planning to like start a
Constitutional democracy is the one that bugged me the most
Like that's, that's the one that actually kind of made me going wait what
you know the coats the like the clothing the
Everybody the the big Vegas party all of that, you know, I was like, okay
There's like I'm gonna start a Constitutional Republic in Nottingham.
I don't know. That's the one that kind of
kind of got me also that then he becomes like this like political revolutionary who at the very end turns into
The the fascist Sheriff of Nottingham because his girlfriend hooked up with her ex
Even though he was like 100 percent on board with her with their rebellion until until the moment that he's like no
No
My girl kissed another man
She is spoiled forever. I'm gonna become the villain
Show you
Oh
Also, he gets like his ear burnt off. So there's like a whole two-faced reveal. The Batman parallels
Just keep going
Like they really just keep going Friar Tuck and Maid Marian have their plan
their plot like their plot, which
basically
they're looking for essentially the same information as
as
Robin and John are
Except they actually know what they're looking for
Where Robin and John are still at the stage of like we need to figure out what's going on
Even though the answer is just like I don't know
Yeah, that's the reason why they can't tell otherwise they would have to basically jump over an entire stage of the plot
Yeah
So so Tuck and Marian are already on the stage of figuring out what we're basically proving that there is a conspiracy
and so
During the party they break into some room full of documents and find a bunch. They're basically they find a bunch of like
ledgers in Arabic, they're basically just straight-up like, okay
seven thousand troops and
Here's here's how much money we're going to pay for these seven thousand troops signed by the Sheriff of Nottingham
And I will keep that in my in my filing cabinet
With the rest of my important documents gotta leave a paper trail
On this you want to get a receipt when you're dealing with the Turks. I tell you what
It's the whole conspiracy plot that ultimately just like
Drives me the the that I think tips me over the edge
because one it's like very ham-handed is very poorly handled all of the villains are like
mustache twirling and just like say exactly
What they're everybody just says exactly what they're thinking. There's multiple times. It's like he's like no Robin. I know the real you
You're the Hood
Loxley is the disguise and
It's like I know writers who use subtext and they're all cowards
But then it's it's like what what's the sheriff's what's the sheriff's plan?
it's like well, he's got this convoluted plan to like undermine for it's like
Just money like they can't just make the acquisition of money
They can't just hoarding wealth. They can't just leave it at hoarding wealth
Because that would just then condemn
Robin because
Oh, he's willing to sell information about the English to the other side for money or he's willing to but then he
would be getting money from he would then be getting money from
the Turks instead of
taking all of the money from the people of Nottingham and
Putting the money to evil evil uses. Yeah. Yeah, the the simple acquisition of wealth can't be
the problem because that would condemn Robin for being you know a
Wealthy person in a feudal system where like he basically straight-up owns people
The movie is very sure not to not to condemn Robin for his vast wealth
So, yeah, so Robin Hood Sicario 2082 1282
Zero-dark Loxley I
I compiled many I compiled many of them. Yeah